Victorian by Neumann let's start there
some of the most impactful important
humans who have ever lived in Computing
why were they wrong so I worked with uh
Andy Gleason who was touring's
counterpart so just just for background
if anybody doesn't know Turing is
credited with the modern architecture of
computing
among many other things Andy Gleason was
his U.S counterpart and you might not
have heard of Andy Gleason but you might
have heard of the Hilbert problems and
Andy Gleason solved the fifth one
so he was a really notable mathematician
during the war he was throwing his
counterpart then van Neumann is credited
with the modern architecture of
computing and one of his students was
Marvin Minsky so I could ask Marvin what
Johnny was thinking and I could ask Andy
what Alan was thinking
and what came out from that what I came
to appreciate
as background I never understood the
difference between computer science and
physical science but
touring's machine that's the foundation
of modern Computing has a simple physics
mistake
which is the head is distinct from the
tape so in the turing machine there's a
head that programmatically moves and
reads and writes the tape the head is
distinct from the tape which means
Persistence of information is separate
from interaction with information yeah
then van Neumann wrote deeply and
beautifully about many things but not
Computing he wrote a horrible men memo
called the first draft of a report on
the edvac which is how you program a
very early computer in it he essentially
roughly took turing's architecture and
built it into a machine
so the legacy of that is the computer
somebody's using to watch this is
spending much of its effort moving
information from Storage Transit
transistors to processing transistors
even though they have the same
computational complexity so in computer
science when you learn about Computing
there's a ridiculous taxonomy of about a
hundred different models of computation
but they're all fictions in physics a
patch of space occupies space
it stores state it takes time to Transit
and you can interact that is the only
model of computation that's physical
everything else is a fiction
so I I really came to appreciate that a
few years back when I did a keynote for
the annual meeting of the supercomputer
industry and then went into the halls
and spent time with the supercomputer
Builders and came to appreciate
oh see if you're familiar with the movie
The Metropolis uh people would frolick
upstairs in the gardens and down in the
basement people would move levers and
that's how Computing exists today that
we pretend software is not physical it's
separate from hardware and the whole
Canon of Computer Science is based on
this fiction that bits aren't
constrained by atoms but all sorts of
scaling issues and Computing come from
that boundary but all sorts of
opportunities come from that boundary
and so you can trace it all the way back
to turing's machine making this mistake
between the head and the tape Von
Neumann in in
um create he never called it vinomen's
architecture he wrote about it in this
Dreadful memo and then he wrote
beautifully about other things we'll
talk about now to end a long answer
Turing and Von Neumann both knew this so
all of the Canon of computer scientists
credits them for what was never meant to
be a computer architecture
both Turing and Van Neumann ended their
life studying
exactly how software becomes Hardware so
van Neumann studied self-reproducing
automata how a machine communicates its
own construction
a touring studied morphogenesis how
genes give rise to form they ended their
life studying the embodiment of
computation something that's been
forgotten by the Canon of computing but
developed sort of off to the sides by a
really interesting lineage
so there's no distinction between the
head and the tape between the computer
and the computation it is all
computation right so I never understood
the difference between computer science
and physical science and working at that
boundary helped lead to things like my
lab was part of doing with a number of
interesting collaborators the first
faster than classical Quantum
computations we were part of a
collaboration creating the minimal
synthetic organism where you design life
in a computer those both involve domains
where you just can't separate Hardware
from software the embodiment of
computation is embodied in these really
profound ways